[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning a
popular home
test to screen for colon cancer has been
followed by an unexpected
medical bill for some people leading the
concerns they may put off life-saving
care
we're investigating this as part of our
series medical price roulette in
collaboration
with clear health costs colon cancer can
be highly treatable if it's caught early
and colonoscopies are provided at no
cost to most people over 45.
our consumer investigative correspondent
anna werner joins us anna good morning
good morning anthony you may have seen
this home test in tv commercials a
product
called cola guard advertised as a way to
screen for colon cancer at home
instead of through the much more
involved process of colonoscopy
now experts say the test is a good
screening tool but some people say after
using it
they were faced with a high bill
you're clearly someone who takes care of
yourself so why wait to screen for colon
cancer
you may have seen these frequent
commercials for coal guard
a mail-in colon cancer screening kit
that tests stool for blood and other
abnormalities
tell me more i had seen the commercial
for
you know a couple years probably
fifty-five-year-old leanne bryant of
missouri was intrigued
i thought hey this screening at home
that i can do sounds pretty easy
compared to full-blown colonoscopy
so in august she called her insurance
company they said yes
they would be fully covered because i
didn't want to be caught with
an unexpected bill she sent in her
sample and waited for an email with her
results
to her surprise the test came back
positive
i could have a polyp i could have colon
cancer
she needed a colonoscopy after all to
her relief it was normal
but then the bills started arriving i
start getting
statements from my hospital saying that
i have a balance of
nineteen hundred dollars i'm thinking
well i'm certainly don't know that much
i mean that that's not possible but it
was
under the affordable care act only
routine screening tests are covered
because bryant's coliguard result was
positive her colonoscopy was coded as an
uncovered diagnostic test turns out her
insurance company refused to fully cover
her
because she used coal guard first i am
mad because
i pay so much every month for this
insurance i just feel like i'm really
getting raked over
cbs news surveyed 11 of the largest
health insurers in the u.s to see what
they would do
in situations like bryant's seven didn't
respond
the four who did told us that coverage
decisions vary
and how much a consumer will pay depends
on how doctors code the colonoscopy
procedure
unfortunately in some cases people with
a positive non-invasive test like
cola guard will have to pay out of
pocket to get their colonoscopy
the university of michigan's dr mark
fendrick who studies medical pricing
problems
worries when people find out their
colonoscopies might not be covered they
won't get them
even with a risk of having colon cancer
the fact that the people who are deemed
to be at higher risk
that it's not easy financially or
otherwise to get the colonoscopy
makes absolutely no sense to me so what
does the manufacturer of coal guard have
to say
exact sciences ceo kevin conroy agrees
there's a problem
if one person gets a bill associated
with
screening it's one person too many but
after we started asking questions conroy
says the company decided it needed to
add new language to its website
saying although millions of patients
have access to this follow-up
colonoscopy with no out-of-pocket costs
not all do you raising this
help us help highlight what we can do
better and so we're always looking for
ways to improve
i'm cola guard but we noticed that those
frequent tv ads
although noting that the cola guard cost
itself is covered by most
insurance don't mention that a follow-up
colonoscopy
may not be covered could you add
something to the television ads which
are what most people
see just to give them a heads up about a
potential unexpected bill
we think what we're doing is so
appropriate
if what you do is scare people away from
getting screened all together
there is a significant cost associated
with that leanne bryant says she wishes
those
ads had given her some warning i don't
want to say it's a sham but
in a way it's just kind of taken
advantage of people
if it happened to me i know that it's
going to happen to a lot of people
researcher fendrick says any problems
with the ads wouldn't matter if the
entire colon cancer screening process
was required to be covered by insurance
i'm hopeful that your story will not
only raise awareness among
your watchers but also among the payers
for them to see how
really irrational that policy is
well cola guard does have a program to
help people file an appeal if they do
get that unexpected bill for a follow-up
colonoscopy bryant by the way finally
won her appeal with her insurance
company to get
her 1900 bill paid but it took her five
months
to get it resolved and we want to hear
from other people guys by the way
health costs at cbsnews.com if you have
a medical billing
story to tell us please email me yeah
definitely it's amazing what happens
when anna werner calls yeah things
change
1900 is a lot when you're not expecting
it i'm glad it
worked out for her yeah and
colonoscopies those bills can be really
high
they oftentimes are two or three
thousand dollars so it's not an
insignificant cost
for a lot of people we get a lot of
emails about colonoscopies
yes i've had one of those or two or
three highly recommended
thank you hannah